- What's up with it brother.
- [Gary] Life is good, man.
- No complaints.
- [Gary] No man, just
as long as, I just need
like four or five core
people to be healthy
and then I'm good.
How are you doin'?
- Man, never better man.
- That's good, man.
That makes me happy.
- Never better.
Just running around, making my rounds.
- How are you thinking about.
It's super interesting for me from afar.
And obviously, you know,
just in culture I know about you.
And then obviously Kenny
Austin's a good friend.
- Right.
- And I know
all about that and Boyd, and everything.
It's super interesting to me,
because I feel like
your
your story and how you roll
is why I like hip hop so much.
Because I think of it more as
hustling and entrepreneurship,
than even necessarily the music.
- Absolutely.
- How are you thinking
about how ridiculous
your opportunity is in
the next 30, 40 years?
- Right.
- Because
you've got so much fucking leverage.
- Right, right.
- Like, people really talk
good shit behind your back
that know you.
- Right.
- Like, whether it's cliche Beats by Dre
or what I'm up to, which is buying brands.
Like, your ability to
create real wealth creation
is unique in your space.
And I was really excited to meet you.
Just to get a sense of how
you're thinking about that.
Like for example, I think you should buy.
I think you should buy Wheaties.
- Right.
- For like, I'm being serious.
- Real sick.
- Like that's what I think you can do.
- Right.
- I think a lot of kids
are going to make money.
But you're an entrepreneur.
Like when I look at you, I look
at you entrepreneur, comma.
- Right.
- Artist.
At least from afar, I don't
know you well enough yet.
But it's real obvious to me.
You know, you could always,
you could always sense your own from afar.
- Right, well that's how it works, though.
You feel the energy.
I mean, for me it's just like.
That was my thing.
I even got into music off
of being an entrepreneur.
- Well that's what.
I know enough to know like.
I feel like you're using
music as your gateway setup
for your mogul ambitions.
- Right, it's a soundtrack.
Just to keep you tuned in,
so you can do other things.
- It's leverage.
- Yeah.
- It's fucking leverage.
- That's the vehicle.
It's definitely a vehicle.
- One thing that's real cool too,
that I wanted to note is like,
what we do and how we do all
these branding partnerships,
there's an.
- I feel bad about his people.
We can get them in here.
- Yeah, let them come in.
- Let's get them in here.
I know this dude was like, let's get out,
but we'll make room for them.
Can you take all this garbage out?
- That's what you say "we", you know.
I can see that.
- Yeah man.
My whole thing is like.
What up, my man?
- [Friend] Yo.
- Real pleasure.
How are things?
Good.
Take a seat right there.
My whole thing, I was
telling A Rod the other day.
He was like "Oh, I'm gonna make
an app, and make this money.
"Me and J Lo."
I'm like "Dude, you need to
buy fucking Fruit of the Looms,
"and put your freaking sexy
asses in those underwear,
"with J Lo, and buy that for $130 million,
"and sell it for a billion."
- Right.
- Like, even what you did with
with Avion.
I think it's time.
Now it's very obvious
to me that the next step
in the game of the thing
that drives our culture,
which is fucking hip hop,
is first it was like you got
a couple do-, you got pennies.
Then they became silver.
Then it went to paper.
But, you know, and you know this.
And you've done it
probably outside of like
three or four other artists
better than anybody.
The next step is fucking
for real, for real.
And that's why I do think like Wheaties.
- Right.
- What I'm building here is,
I want to build a machine, a death star.
And then I want to buy Tylenol
or Wheaties, or K-Swiss.
That's why I did a
collaboration with them.
I want to buy big as fucking businesses,
and run them through my culture machine,
which is different than
your culture machine,
and make real fucking economics.
- Right.
- Timbos.
You need to buy Timberland, the brand.
And fucking reboot it.
- Right.
- Because you're not going
to put up all $380 million.
- Right.
- I mean,
I don't know your paper, but that's a lot.
But there's a lot of people.
You could own 25% of it.
- Right.
- And fucking get
15 people to put up $30
million checks each.
And then buy Timbo for $280,
and sell it for $3.1 billion
seven years later.
That's the next step
if you're really playing
what I at least think you
have the potential to play.
- Absolutely.
That's what.
- It's nice
to make two bucks a bottle
on some fucking cognac.
But that's a whole different
thing than buying Starter.
Rebooting.
You see what's going on with Champion.
Champion was bullshit 24 months ago.
- [Friend] Yup.
- You saw what was going on with Fila.
You see what's going
on with Tommy Hilfiger.
- Right.
- Like where's fucking Nautica right now?
Garbage.
You fucking get behind it,
and get fucking Atlanta
behind it, and it's back.
And you're not gonna.
And what you and a lot of your homies
aren't thinking about just yet,
and I didn't think about
this back in the day either.
Is you don't have to put up all the money.
- Right.
- You need to be the
machine that goes through.
You'll put up five million, a million.
I don't want to count your money.
You could put up some money.
But you can raise the rest,
and get 20% for being the machine.
- Right.
- That's the next step, man.
Honestly, jeez, like.
That's where, that's
where you buy the Hawks,
instead of sitting court side.
- No doubt, talk that shit.
Talk it.
- I really think you've got
that potential from afar.
- Right.
- I really do.
I think there's four, five people who can.
And I know you can be.
Because you are a businessman first.
- Right.
- A lot of people are now
saying it because it's cool.
But they're artists first, comma.
They wanna be an entrepreneur,
because it's the flavor of the decade.
But that show will be over once
everyone loses their money.
- Wow.
Always does.
- Always does.
That's right, exactly.
But you need to be thinking that way.
- Right, and I'm locked in.
I'm definitely.
I mean, I never thought
Wheaties, but shit.
(laughter)
- You need like, right?
I think people think too much.
When you're cool, you
think about cool products.
But like, there's nothing
wrong with blow pops.
And you can make a lot
of things cool, too.
- Right.
- Like.
- Like your K-Swiss.
Like Gary, this is Gary's K-Swiss shoe.
- Dope.
- And you know a lot of
people in hip hop with the
Nike or Adidas, or whatever.
But when he went to
K-Swiss, it's kind of like.
- Because I want to
buy, I want to buy Pony.
- Right.
- And get Spud Webb's
ass to put them back on,
and bring it back, you know?
Like, nostalgia.
Nostalgia's underpriced.
That's my biggest thesis.
So like, what did you grow up eating?
What did you grow up wearing?
That's not relevant now.
First thing I did when
I did the K-Swiss joint
was I went on Google,
and found pictures of
fucking Doctor Dre,
Ice Tea, everybody
wearing fucking K-Swisses.
Mike Tyson in his prime.
Because I remember, right?
How old are you?
- 38.
- Right, so you might
remember it a little bit,
but I don't know.
- And you?
- 40 something.
- Right.
(laughter)
- But that's what I thought.
Which means you should remember, right?
And that's what I'm studying all my time.
I'm building a fucking
big ass fucking machine.
And then whatever the fuck I buy,
deploy that fucking army
behind it, and go hard.
Because it's very obvious,
culture will accept anything back.
You've just got to make it contemporary.
And the way you have leverage,
like I need business men that
are in the fashion business
in Italy, and they're like,
"When I'm in Atlanta, I go meet
Jeezy, and take a picture."
Like you have something for real.
- I hear you.
- It's just the truth.
- Loud and clear.
- So that's what.
- We got to feel it though.
Because this is my guy right here.
He already put me in pocket one time, so.
I can imagine that me and you sit down,
we start building on it.
- Yeah man, and that,
you're talking about Avion?
- Yes.
- My man.
I'll, you know.
That happened because me and
fucking Ken Austin sat there.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, like.
It's way beyond that.
That's five fucking years ago.
- Right.
- Like, it's.
Like what I'm talking about is
it's way better than it was back then.
We didn't have.
You and I didn't have the
leverage with Kenny back then.
- Right.
- Meaning,
we were still in endorse.
Social media, entrepreneurs
like you and me,
we still were in endorsement mode.
Now we don't need.
Now you can sell fucking
shit direct to consumer.
Like you make that hoodie.
You don't need Macy's.
You don't need Target.
You don't need Walmart.
Shit's about to get crazy.
Like the people that have the leverage
are the people closest to the people.
Got it?
- That was.
- Because everything in the
middle's commoditized now.
You don't have to be good,
and go to Bentonville,
and get Walmart to put you on.
You don't have to be on television,
and spend ten million dollars.
So now that the middle's
been commoditized,
and you and me,
and all the leverage is going to us.
- We were just talking about (mumbles).
- Yeah, they're good people.
- That's exactly like.
That's what he's doing.
Like the sweater, the
hoodie, like the snowman.
- I know.
- Everything.
Like you're doing alright.
The craziest thing that you've done.
- Like, you being the snowman is like,
go buy an ice cream brand.
And parlay that shit.
Right?
Like go buy like.
Go buy a fucking ice cream brand.
And buy it from Unilever
when they fucked it up
for like $49 million.
Make it hot, and sell it back
to fucking Coca Cola for $280.
And make $240 quick.
And that's real money.
My man right here, right?
Cool kid, right?
Look what he's wearing, he's wearing Vans.
Like four years ago, that
brand has got no pulse.
But it did 12 years ago, and 19 years ago.
Remember OP and Jams and fucking.
We can sit here and go down memory lane.
All those opportunities.
- Damn.
- That's how I'm thinking.
- The greatest thing is like,
when you start working with Avion, right?
Your first tweet or your first IG post,
I don't know if anyone told you this,
the sales went up like crazy in Detroit.
And that makes sense.
Because not only you
know, Atlanta whatever,
but he's hot in Detroit.
- I know.
- Whatever, whatever.
Everyone has their own cities, right?
But where you took that
brand is unbelievable.
And like, when we do
all these brand deals,
a lot of things they don't
last a year, two years, like.
And how many years you've been doing it?
- Now you got the water.
- That's because
the one thing with him that's different,
is the youngsters fuck
with him on a respect level
that's different.
That's why I'm going to win.
It's not how cool or big I'm going to be.
17 million Instagram
followers in four years
is going to be great.
And it'll be cool.
But it's not going to make people like.
I'm not going to be able to move America
to all of a sudden by myself,
give a fuck about whatever
I deployed that against.
The thing you have is the
tentacles as an entrepreneur
and businessman within people
who are moving culture.
It doesn't matter what
the Migos are doing.
It matters who the Migos look up to.
That's where scale comes in, man.
You understand?
That's how.
- Guys grew up listening to you.
- A hundred, of course!
- Everyone on Facebook
grew up listening to you.
- Right.
- A hundred percent.
- Yeah.
- It's the influence.
It's not your own sheer.
You fucking.
Like I, fuck man, you
could move a product with.
Without you ever posting
it on social ever once.
It's the people underneath
you that fuck with you.
That's scale for real.
Who are moving the needle.
And you've got favors in your pocket.
- Right.
- I know.
I've done a lot of homework.
You've got favors in your pocket.
So favors are smart when
you're going for a billion.
Like if you go and spend, you know.
If you go and raise capital
from a bunch of wealthy people,
and have $280 million
and then go and buy Fila.
And the mission is for next
four years, seven years.
Real time.
Not 12 months.
To get that and sell it
to Nike for $2.3 billion,
because they're whack in 2029,
and they need a hot brand.
That's when you call
in every fucking favor.
- Right.
- That's what I do.
All I'm doing right now
is trying to bring value.
Because one day I'm going to
care about something for real.
(laughter)
- Damn.
- You understand?
That's where I'm at.
Like I'm not.
You understand?
I got leverage with everybody.
I'm just giving, giving,
even with you, through him.
That's give, give, give.
- I see and you wanna get back.
- And the best part for me is,
and I don't know you.
The key to that whole system
is not to be disappointed
when people don't come through.
- Okay.
- I've got, I don't know you and I.
And I know I'm unusual with this.
Like I could do everything for Boyd.
And I've done a lot for him.
And if I ask him for a favor,
for real, in two years,
and he says no,
for some reason that doesn't fuck with me.
It cripples my dad.
Cripples him.
But for me, I'm like.
Not going to worry about what
was going through his mind.
I don't have time to analyze
what was going through
his mind at this minute,
where he didn't understand the score.
It's like that Bronx Tale
movie, where the guy is like,
"You got off easy because
that kid owes you 20 bucks.
"You know he's a piece of shit."
You remember that little scene?
Like that's how I think about it.
Like if I go in for the ask,
and it doesn't come through,
I might be sad for a 100th of a second.
Just be like "Fuck!"
You know, like I helped
that dude for real.
Like why the fuck?
You know.
(laughter)
what's that?
Because looking back, our defense loses.
It's pretty bad defense in football.
You were winning the whole game.
And now you decide with
two minutes left to change
your defense because
there's two minutes left,
and they score a touchdown.
That's like classic.
That's life.
I don't care who stole money from me.
It just saves me time
to go on the offense.
So that's what I'm trying to collect.
I'm trying to collect real
partnerships and real friends.
For 20, 30.
You know, we may be in our 40s, but like,
I fuck with people.
The dude who built this real
estate project for $20 billion,
he's 77, and he's hot.
He texted me just now, he's like,
"Let's do Saturday morning breakfast."
Steve Ross, owns the Dolphins.
Like, he's a straight fucking gangster.
He's got as much energy as you and me.
Wants it, still hungry as fuck.
77.
When you're an entrepreneur,
you're not playing on your looks.
You're not playing on your swag.
You know?
- Yeah.
- So.
I think we got 40 more
years of real game time.
- Right, the real 40.
- I think so.
- We're much smarter than we used to be.
- You right about that.
- You know?
Like that's the best part
of not being an athlete.
Athlete's get slower,
entrepreneur's get smarter.
- Right.
Hm, never thought about it like that.
You know we've definitely got to do.
(laughter)
We should do Sunday morning.
- One thing you can help me with,
I'm looking to go hard
at Atlanta next year.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna, my next huge drop,
I'm definitely gonna launch party there.
- Okay.
- I'm going to go to two to three
Hawk games a year.
In the back half of, next
year during the season.
Sit court side, just like.
Atlanta's literally the seed of culture.
In my opinion.
- Wow.
- [Friend] Nah, it is.
- It really is.
Because that's where hip
hop's culture's epicenter is.
And then hip hop's culture
becomes white kid's culture.
It's just.
It's the bed rock.
So I'm going to make a
real commitment to it.
We're going to be coming through a lot.
- When we're in Atlanta, we'll hit you up.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Every time.
- Does he and Richie
South know each other?
- You never met.
- South?
- So I manage a crew with Richie South.
He's with Future and thugs and guy.
He did "All the Smoke", and he
did "I Am" with Chris Brown.
- Nah nah.
- He's from south side.
- Okay, yeah.
He's with that camp.
That mafia?
- He's cool with south side,
but he's with Future every day.
- Okay.
- But, uh.
- You should meet him.
- He's a living legend.
(overlapping speech)
I hit up stone cold treasure
last time I was in Atlanta,
but that is south.
You're going to meet him some day soon.
- Let's put it together.
- That's inevitable.
But you should meet him.
He's a good kid.
Coming up real.
- Okay.
- What else?
What can I help you guys with?
What else is on your mind?
Because I know I went (vomit noise).
- No, I would love you just.
- I've been waiting
for this meeting.
I wanted to tell you what's on my mind.
I didn't even wait.
- I just would just love,
you know, to continue to
build, you know what I mean?
And stay in pocket.
Because I've definitely paid.
- Listen.
You could hit me every minute.
This is my framework.
This is an advertising agency.
We work with all the biggest brands.
Budweiser, all sorts of brands.
Right?
Chase Bank and Pepsi, Mountain Dew.
And all this stuff.
But it's a front.
I literally think of this
whole $150 million company.
It is, I'm being dead serious.
This entire $150 million
is like a cleaner's
in the Bronx in 1972,
and downstairs is the casino.
- Right, right.
- That's what this is.
Everything I do here
is not about making money.
Let me chop it up a different way.
We can do a buck 50 in revenue this year.
I'm making one million,
1.7 million profit.
I'll make more money
speaking six times this year
than this whole company will make me.
- Wow.
- Because I'm investing
into the fucking machine.
So that when I buy
you know, Bubblicious,
I'm going to be able to turn it,
and make everybody fuck with it.
- Right, because you got the machine.
- The machine.
- That's real life.
- Right?
- Right.
- I think you have a
weird machine, from afar,
you have a how people
fuck with you machine.
I think if you organize,
you might really be able to build
something really substantial man.
You're sitting in the epicenter of,
I think, China's coming up,
but like America's still
the brand in the world.
And I do think this is the fucking place.
But fuck man, I think Atlanta's culture.
And I think you need
to be super thoughtful
about how much leverage that actually is.
I think you guys take it for granted.
Because, you know?
It just feels normal.
- We in it.
- You're so in it.
- It feels normal, you
take it for granted.
Like,
I just think it's fucking really matters.
Like at a level that fucking confuses me.
Meaning like, just watching it go from
LA Reid, and now just watching it
my whole life.
Like the leverage is so real.
- It's only continuing to grow, too.
- The thing with, the thing
that fucks with me the most
is the difference between 21
Savage, Rus, the Migos, like.
Danny Glover, the Hollywood
shit that's happening
in the suburbs.
There's so much really happening.
That's what I'm good at.
I'm good at people's attention.
That's why I invested in
Facebook and Twitter and Uber
before everybody else.
I knew what was going to happen.
I really think you guys can
build some big ass businesses.
- I'm all over it.
I'm totally open.
- Do you know what private equity is?
- Absolutely.
- Good.
- Find every single private
equity firm in Atlanta
and just start networking.
Really understand it.
Because the new version of private equity
is what I think you need
to be thinking about.
Private equity people
would get everybody to put up the money.
They would keep 20% of the action.
And they went to Harvard and
Yale and had finance degrees,
and worked at Goldman Sachs.
I think the next version of them.
There's just something.
You know, music is one of
the four to five things that
humans give a fuck about.
- Right.
- Right?
And fashion's another one.
And now you're on like
two of the fucking five
things people give a fuck about.
- Right.
- So, one thing I would give
you huge piece of advice.
Don't let any vulnerability
happen in Atlanta
from your status of who
you are to the people
that are 28 to 31.
26 to 35, you need to make sure 15 to 25
looks at you the same way they did.
I didn't bring up Richie South for us.
I brought up Richie for you.
- Right.
- Do you understand?
- You have leverage.
- Right.
- Same reason that all
the fucking hip hop kids
coming through and meeting with me,
I have leverage as an
entrepreneur, you know?
Fucking athlete and
fucking artist give a fuck
about me four years ago.
Now entrepreneurship matters, now they do.
My biggest piece of advice
is get somebody, yourself,
I don't know your crew,
to really have your ear to all this shit.
And get to those kids super fucking early,
and just give them love.
Build fucking real leverage.
Like I'm on fucking Facetime
with Gunna every day.
- Right.
- You know?
Get in early.
Because then it's giving them real love.
And then they're going to
be the fucking framework
of the thing that you're going to actually
want to pull off.
- Legit.
- And you have leverage.
You fucking DM'ed fucking
Young Thug 18 months ago.
He was losing his fucking mind.
Less today.
- Yeah, it's real.
It's really real.
- You know, that's really
what matters to me.
Because that's a big
leverage point for you.
- Right.
I get it, totally.
- Of course, because it's what
you fucking did to get here.
- Right.
- But this is the time you
triple down on that shit.
And what most people do at
this point is go the other way.
They get fancy.
- Right.
I'm ready to get my hands dirty.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm ready to.
Jump in head first, man.
But we definitely gonna have to build.
Definitely, I'm with that totally.
And I,
- What are you
guys working on now?
Like what's on your mind?
Obviously, I've seen some of
the new project and all that.
- So, putting the new project out.
Just finished a compound in Atlanta,
which is you know, a studio.
You know, just a whole compound.
So it's going to be easy to run
the young guys through there.
So we got about two rooms.
- Just a, got it.
- Get my own thing going.
Get my.
- Fuck.
You got that now?
- Yes sir.
- You need to get every fucking.
Like I don't know who the
fucking ear is in this crew.
All of you, nobody, like.
You need to fucking get every
one of those kids through.
- [Friend] Yeah.
- It's just leverage.
- Look at this guy.
- Why?
This is the same conversation
I have with him every day.
- Because he's the gate keeper?
- Yeah, but he's,
but I have this conversation
with him everyday.
- How so?
- Same conversation we're having.
- That we need to get these kids through?
- Yeah, everyday.
- And what do you think?
Gotta be selective or you're cool with it?
- [Friend] Nah, I'm all.
- Seriously.
- [Friend] I'm pretty much cool with it.
- What are you, what's
the pretty much part?
- [Friend] Go back and forward
about it, but you know,
I bring some things to the table.
We've got to weed, got to build.
- Of course.
- [Friend] So you know.
That's pretty much it,
just weeding out the.
- But it's, that's my.
My 2018 plan is to really
just get my hands dirty.
- You're straight fucking
legend to these kids.
- Like I ain't really moving.
- But you know what's crazy,
and people get caught.
People get caught, because you
can get irrelevant real fast.
Like you don't want to
know how many 17 year olds
in Atlanta don't really know.
It happens.
- Just like that.
- You did it to somebody else.
- [Friend] Exactly.
- You know, like I was.
I had a crazy meeting with 50 Cent once.
Where he was trying to say
something, and I was like.
You're not as famous as you think.
- Wow, wow.
- Which was a little bit of a mistake,
because he got mad, but, you know.
He got a little aggressive.
I'm trying to help him.
I'm like what the fuck
do you think you did?
I'm like Big Daddy Kane
wasn't cool for four years.
I remember, you know?
It just happens real quick.
That's your leverage.
Showing them love on the come up.
And you know what's going to happen.
You know, we all know what's happening if.
It's going good for Coach K now.
Right?
- Right.
- Like if he's going to make
a decision to try to put
somebody on for a minute,
you gotta at least take the bet.
It could become Biggy,
it could become Mase.
But it doesn't matter.
It's 50/50.
What, you didn't want
to waste three hours?
Got it?
It's just math.
- What I'm saying.
- You know a machine's going
to try to make them good.
He may suck, he may be great.
But you know the energy of the
machine's going to be behind it.
You know the crews that are winning.
You know, if Metro Boomin's
going to go make a fucking
album with somebody, and you
haven't heard about them,
you better fucking meet them.
He may be great.
He may not.
But, you know he's going
to have a 50/50 chance.
And it's definitely worth three hours
of you fucking with him
and teaching him as the legend.
Somebody needs, you need to own that.
There shouldn't be a single fucking artist
out of Atlanta that comes
out over the next seven years
who doesn't reference you in
their second album of like
thanks for the support.
- Right.
- [Friend] That's real shit.
- Because that's when you buy fucking
that's when you buy something and get all.
And you cash in those chips.
- So they're going to support you.
- Then all of a sudden you
make $700 million on a flip.
Got it?
- Got it.
- All on just what.
First of all, they're going to help you.
That three hours with somebody that's 19,
that's fucking raw, and that's
got a different perspective.
They're just going to give you
a different perspective, too.
And you're going to know
exactly what to do with it,
which is going to affect
your next project.
- It's like what you're
doing with T-Grizz.
He's helping him.
- Yep.
Times a thousand.
Or 113, but more than one.
- I like the way you put
those numbers together.
(laughter)
- But you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- It's there for you, man.
- I get it.
- If you don't do it,
somebody else is going to take it.
- We can't let them do that.
Can't let them do that.
- You know?
- Yeah, I can't let that happen.
By the way, that's what I'm good at.
So, it's just like.
- Well that's.
Honestly, I'm giving you
advice based on feedback
I've been getting from other people, like.
It's just fucking time.
People love to say they're
going to get their hands dirty.
But then you actually got
to get your hands dirty.
Like it's not, sometimes
you're tight, you know.
You're doing mogul life.
Like sometimes you get,
this kid who's got, who
wants like, you know.
You're taking risk.
Your time is your biggest fucking asset.
But it's where all the leverage is.
- I'm on it.
- Think about everyone who
didn't fuck with 21 Savage
27 months ago that's, fuck I
should have taken that meeting.
- We was talking about that this morning.
- Is that right?
- Yep.
- About what?
- Just him.
I heard him on few records,
like records you wouldn't.
I heard one of the Bad
Bunny records, I was like.
- How well do you know Bad Bunny?
Because I saw him on your
video for "Bottles Up".
- Yeah, we kicked it, we
kicked it a few times.
I pulled up on him, but
that's another thing.
- You know what's an
interesting thing for them?
The latino stuff.
I know.
- And you know.
- That to me is the next wave.
- I know we kicked it.
I met him in Miami.
He came to Atlanta.
Reached out, I want to
put him on the show.
Come to the show.
We talked a little bit.
We've been talking about it.
- Trying to make music with those guys?
- We had that conversation.
You know, he doesn't
speak a lot of English.
(laughter)
- There's only so much
you're going to accomplish.
- We just got back from Medillin.
- Right, do you know
somebody from his camp
that speaks English?
- I know a lot of people in that camp,
and most of those people yeah.
But yeah, I know people who
speak English in that world.
- Right, no, I'm just
saying as far as his camp,
that's been the biggest thing.
- Of course.
- It's trying to just
you know, communicate.
- There's a start up I just
looked at that's two years away
from you having earpieces
that you can't even see,
and literally every
language, somebody speaks,
you just translate, and back and forth.
- Wow.
- That's it.
Two years they say.
Five years from now, that
shit is fucking cracked.
- [Friend] It's like Her.
- Mm hm, Her.
Cracked.
Go to China, put in the fucking thing.
Be like "Oh cool, yeah.", like.
- Bad Bunny, like, if
you're the first rapper.
- You need to hack culture, man.
More culture.
Don't get fancy, listen.
I love you and P Diddy.
I love it.
Fucking mogul life, it's iconic shit.
That 19 year old girl in Alpha
Red that doesn't give a fuck.
- Fact, Bad Bunny probably worships you.
If you're his fucking.
- They all worship you
as long as you educate them.
I gotta go?
I gotta go, it's a charity event.
- You got a card I can pick up?
- I don't have a card, but we're gonna.
Let's get numbers.
- Yeah, let's do it.
- And I'm gonna.
- Let's do that asap.
- What' your number?
- I got a new one.
You can listen to it in the morning.
- What you got?
- I got that one.
- Good.
(pop music)